Another day, another failed attempt to execute
SCP-682 - The infamous Hard To Destroy Reptile.
The most recent attempt was SCP-272, an Old
Iron Nail with the ability to pin people’s
shadows to the ground and tear them to shreds
when different configurations of light make
their shadows go haywire.
Just when it seemed like 272 and a high-powered
disco ball might be the thing to win the Foundation’s
war against the misanthropic lizard, it did
what it always did: Pulled out a trump card,
and ruined everything.
Its body evolved a sudden, intense bioluminescence
that completely eliminated the beast’s shadow
by overpowering all other light sources in
the room.
This not only rendered the Foundation’s
strobe lights utterly useless, but blinded
several members of D-Class personnel who were
sent in to check on the beast during testing.
This resulted, predictably, in another Big,
Fat L for the SCP Foundation.
682: 435, Foundation: 0.
And nobody was more frustrated by this than
Dr. Samet.
Samet was a Foundation greenhorn with big
ambitions.
Like every jerk at the office, he was less
concerned with doing his job right, and far
more concerned with climbing the corporate
ladder.
Samet had done all he could to cozy up to
Site Directors and even the Overseers far
above, all with the goal of someday getting
a seat at their high table.
But as any SCP fans know, they’re not just
giving out positions on or just under the
O5 Council.
To swing something like that, you need to
really make an impression.
You need to wow them.
And what would be a better way to do that
than being the person who killed SCP-682?
Surely, if he actually buried that beast,
they’d hand him the keys to the proverbial
castle.
So Dr. Samet had done everything he could
to get reassigned to the 682 termination effort,
and only now was he realizing just how in
over his head he truly was.
Dr. Samet needed help from a higher power.
If he even hoped of beating SCP-682, the man
needed God on his side.
Thankfully, they just so happened to have
God chilling out in his containment cell in
Site 17.
Perhaps, through enlisting the help of earth’s
divine arbiter, he could bring an end to the
scourge of SCP-682 and rocket himself to success
in the process.
However, while Dr. Samet may have been arrogant,
he wasn’t completely delusional.
He knew that he didn’t have the standing
to address SCP-343 directly, much less to
ask him for a hand in destroying SCP-682.
He’d need a go-between.
Someone with tenure, someone who commanded
respect among SCP Foundation staff as well
as the very anomalies they governed.
Perhaps someone who was a little bit anomalous
themselves…
And who better fits this description than
the living legend, Dr. Jack Bright?
Dr. Samet had, of course, read the doctor’s
personnel files.
Everybody at the Foundation knew about Dr.
Bright’s exploits - From what he’s done,
to the various things he isn’t allowed to
do, which we’ll cover in a future video.
He also dug up the SCP-963 files: The anomalous
medallion keeping Dr. Bright alive, whether
he likes it or not.
While a discussion of the exact nature of
the medallion isn’t something you’d want
to have in front of Dr. Bright himself - After
all, it’s a touchy subject - you could make
the argument that the medallion is the real
him.
It’s where his soul is condemned to spend
perhaps the rest of eternity, killing and
stealing the body of anyone or anything that
touched it.
He’d become an immortal parasite, destined
to take the finite lives of others while his
own marches on forever.
Remind you of anyone?
Dr. Samet got into contact with Dr. Bright
and explained his plan: With Bright’s help,
he’d recruit SCP-343, and bring the very
wrath of God down onto the Hard to Destroy
Reptile.
Of course, while Dr. Samet naturally assumed
himself to be the smartest person in the room,
Dr. Bright had a more realistic assessment
of the ambitious young turk’s skills.
He saw Samet for what he truly was: A climber,
a buttkisser, a greedy, power-hungry bureaucrat
wearing a lab coat, and he thought that made
him a researcher?
It was laughable.
What Dr. Bright found less funny, though,
was Dr. Samet’s insistence on calling him
“SCP-963.”
There’s a lot to know about Dr. Bright,
but one thing you should definitely commit
to memory is that you should never, under
any circumstances, call Dr. Bright SCP-963.
And if you were forever entwined with a necklace
that doomed you to watch everyone you know
and love age and die, while depriving you
of that same release, you’d probably resent
being associated with it, too.
Dr. Bright did agree to participate in Dr.
Samet’s harebrained termination scheme,
but with a warning that he did not give lightly:
If ever Dr. Samet called him 963 again, he
would have one of his own loyal team members
- nicknamed The Lucky Bunch, for their high
survival rate compared to other Foundation
research teams - shoot him in the foot.
Dr. Bright steeled himself and entered 343’s
containment cell, where the playful deity
had taken the form of the late comedian George
Burns, complete with his trademark glasses
and half-smoked stogy.
They made small talk, with 343 delivering
his usual high-handed, cryptic parables about
his plans for Dr. Bright, and everybody else.
He even momentarily teased the idea of freeing
him from his curse.
But Dr. Bright knew better than to buy into
these fairy tales.
He talked SCP-343 into a cross test, but didn’t
tell him that it was with 682, or that he
was expected to terminate it.
That was better left as a surprise.
Dr. Samet and Dr. Bright stood in the observation
area outside the cross-testing chamber.
Samet was giddy with excitement and confidence
in this new experiment.
Dr. Bright’s reactions were a hell of a
lot more measured.
He’d been working at the Foundation long
enough now to know that terminating SCP-682
was a fool’s errand.
The only researchers still intent on trying
it were doing so out of stubbornness and ego.
And when 343 and 682 were released into the
chamber, Dr. Bright’s healthy pessimism
was more than justified.
682 attacked a nearby door, attempting to
breach containment, while 343 looked around,
confused and seemingly unable to see anything.
When he was ordered to kill 682, he was shocked
to learn 682 was even in the room.
He stormed off moments later in a huff, saying,
“He's not one of mine.
Deal with him yourself.”
Dr. Bright was unsurprised.
Dr. Samet was shocked and furious.
How could this have failed?
They literally had God on their side!
This setback would seriously compromise his
chances of rising through the ranks, unless
he found a quick way to make the best out
of a bad situation and save face.
Without even thinking, he turned to Dr. Bright
and said:
“Fine.
It didn't work.
Doesn't matter.
Get yourself ready 963, you're going in.”
So it was decided.
Dr. Bright himself would face off with SCP-682
in SCP-343’s place.
Dr. Bright was a betting man, he loved a good
game of chance, and he estimated that his
odds of succeeding were exceptionally low.
But what would be the point in refusing?
Even if he couldn’t kill SCP-682, perhaps
he would get lucky, and the reptile would
kill him instead.
So many enticing possibilities.
Dr. Bright left to prepare for the coming
battle.
And, because nobody would say that Dr. Bright
wasn’t a man of his word, he had one of
his assistants shoot Dr. Samet in the foot.
A few days later, Dr. Bright, Dr. Samet - Now
in a wheelchair while he recovered from his
unfortunate foot injury - and a collection
of other researchers, including Dr. Sophia
Light, were convened in a conference room,
planning out their assault on SCP-682.
A mechanical “staff” of sorts was laying
on the table in front of him, a kind of powerful
taser capable of firing out painful bolts
of electricity.
It would be the only object Dr. Bright carried
into the chamber with him that day.
But only as a way of getting 682’s attention,
not as a weapon.
The true weapon was SCP-963.
The plan was simple: SCP-682 would eat Dr.
Bright, and the power of SCP-963 would destroy
it from within.
As anyone with an awareness of 963’s anomalous
properties could tell you, for most living
beings, touching the medallion results in
immediate brain death, followed by the consciousness
of Dr. Bright inhabiting your mindless body.
If they could get this phenomenon to work
for SCP-682, perhaps, with Dr. Bright’s
mind in 682’s body, could they now end the
life of this wretched beast once and for all?
Like with all matters involving SCP-682 and
Dr. Bright, it was most likely not going to
be so simple.
When Dr. Bright entered the test chamber with
682, as Dr. Samet and the others watched from
the observation room, the results were sudden
and violent.
Dr. Bright zapped the monster with his electro-staff,
and it came charging for him, a terrible fury
of teeth and claws.
Dr. Bright had died so many times, and yet,
he couldn’t even recall many experiences
more unpleasant than this.
And as 682’s interior flesh met SCP-963…
Dr. Bright woke up in the middle of a strange
new place.
There was a man standing over him that looked
oddly familiar, except for the strange chainmail
hauberk he was wearing.
When Dr. Bright found his feet, he recognized
the man: It was a D-Class.
In fact, the first body he’d ever inhabited
after his soul fused with SCP-963.
But he wasn’t alone here.
There were so many people, all of them wearing
the same chainmail, and carrying the same
electro-staffs that Dr. Bright had carried
into the chamber with him.
Little by little, he recognized every single
one of the faces: They were all people whose
bodies he’d taken.
Whose lives he’d cut short, to further his
own.
He looked around and saw more bizarre sights:
A grand castle, structured like a deranged
Escher painting.
And up above, drowning out the sky, was a
great, reptilian behemoth, like SCP-682 on
steroids, made entirely from barbecue sauce.
The D-Class broke the surreal news: None of
this was real, it was a fantasy his mind had
concocted to help him cope with his consciousness
bonding with SCP-682.
A more palatable way of perceiving his new
reality.
And if he ever wanted to get out and be himself
again, he would need to fight and conquer
the beast within.
Dr. Bright joined forces with his past victims,
including one former Level 2 Researcher, Damon
Smith.
Together, using their electro-staffs, Bright
and his army of mental constructs blasted
the great monster in the sky from the safe
confines of the castle.
However, things weren’t quite as safe as
Dr. Bright had first imagined.
The massive creature descended upon them,
tearing the castle to shreds with its huge
claws.
The construct of Damon Smith was devoured
in the process.
Dr. Bright’s brief illusion of victory was
soon stifled by one immutable fact: You could
not defeat SCP-682.
He retreated from the monster into the darkness
of his own nightmares.
From there, he woke up.
Dr. Bright was in a hospital bed, the medallion
attached to a new body after 682’s body
had rejected it.
He was greeted by Dr. Sophia Light and a member
of the O5 Council.
Dr. Bright had effectively been gone for days.
When he asked what happened on the outside,
he was told that 682 had entered a 36-hour
coma, before growing massive claws and tunneling
out of containment, where it caused a massive
breach.
Though strangely, upon breaking out of the
chamber, it only attacked one researcher…
And in unrelated news, Dr. Samet had been
taken off the 682 case.
It didn’t take long for things to return
to normal for Dr. Bright - Well, as normal
as life can be when you’re a man as strange
as him - but while few would notice it, 682
was left altered.
It had taken a souvenir from Dr. Bright: Fragments
of the consciousness of Damon Smith.
It felt his pain, his fear.
It tasted it, dissected it, and now understood
it.
And when the opportunity presented itself
once more, as it always did, he couldn’t
wait to inflict it on others...
Now go check out “SCP-682 - Ways SCP Foundation
Tried to Kill Hard To Destroy Reptile” and
“How to Kill SCP-682 - Theories and Ideas”
for more entries in the seemingly endless
quest to finally put SCP-682 in the ground
for good!